sean connery je suis en train de me
demander en regardant cette séquence il
y a une une limite d'âge pour jouer
james bond james bond de 50,3 si je
pensais un nouveau film il faudrait deux
ans pour le faire et ce serait un moment
parfait pour que quelqu'un en place sean
connery
on a dit tout à l'heure que vous ne
vouliez plus jouer james bond mais je
veux savoir comment s'est déroulée votre
première rencontre avec jean ping est
arrivé c'était très simple film devenait
de plus en plus long et ça prenait de
plus en plus de temps les effets
spéciaux étaient très importants et on
l'est de plus en plus loin du scénario
du livre de flemming les producteurs
étaient de plus en plus gourmands
saltzman des brocolis et il n'y avait
pas de contraintes financières
c'est-à-dire qu'ils pouvaient continuer
à faire un film de plus en plus long si
bien que j'ai décidé de terminer d'aller
ailleurs
j'ai fait deux ou trois films par an
alors que les films de bound vous on ne
vit que de voitures et ciment gestion
artistique non vous avez fait des films
arrivent boorman avec lui mais qu
d'ailleurs la cinémathèque va vous
rendre un hommage spécial avec un film
inédit aux fans ce mercredi en baisse
lourdement monde eh bien oui je suis
très heureux et très honoré
des fans me dire un fun je dois
remercier denis pétant qui a fait un
travail magnifique ce film a été fait
pour youn est le fils n'a jamais été
montré en france
j'ai vu deux il avait marché en
australie au japon et je j'ai une
affinité spéciale avec la france
notamment qui était là le premier pays à
reconnaître certains de mes films comme
la colline et rené marion et d'autres
films également alors qu'en angleterre
ça n'a pas toujours été le cas
je ne connais vous avez joué d'autres
vous venez de dire que jazz omesc
finalement ce rôle s'il vous a rapporté
beaucoup d'argent nous a pas gênés dans
votre cas est ce que partout vous voyez
pas une seconde même si vous jouiez
autre chose non c'est évidemment quelque
chose qui existe est si je n'avais pas
fait james bond je n'aurais pas été en
mesure de faire les autres films ça a
été au fond 50% beaucoup d'argent et 50%
travailler à perte mais au cours des ans
ça s'équilibre bien ça ne fait que 29
ans que je fais des films je m'en suis
aperçue hier
vous parlez souvent de l'argent beaucoup
d'argent à propos de james bond est ce
qu'on peut savoir combien vous avez été
payés pour incarner le dernier james
bond je sais que c'est public donc vous
l'avais déjà dit non je n'ai jamais dit
et le public est d un peu trompé dans ce
sens je n'ai jamais dit non plus comme
je n'avais pas gagné d'argent en
principe je ne dit pas combien je gagne
sur un film ou sur un contrat est ce que
vous êtes déjà pris chez une connerie ce
que vous est déjà pris pour james bond
mais avec ma charge au beijing may mois
un an
non vraiment je crois que j'ai beaucoup
fait pour introduire l'aspect
humoristique du caractère c'est à dire
que je me suis aussi occupé du scénario
one je devins que dis je m'en fous je
pense qu'on n'en tienne les cas votre
avis si vous deviez donner une
définition de james bond qui est james
bond
comment se présente-t-il washington
quand je crois que certains aimeraient
qu'il soit géré je servais pays où je
responsable parce qu'il a l'air de
résoudre tous les problèmes qui se
posent à lui vous êtes une formule très
démodé de mettre quelqu'un dans des
situations intenables et l'amener à
résoudre tous les problèmes tout en noir
gens bien du vin bien et ont d'ailleurs
toutes les jeunes les femmes et dans la
vie je crois que ça ne se passe pas tout
à fait comme s'il pensait pas qu'un vous
ne pensez pas qu un être humain normal
puisse être j'ai mis mon nom mais match
perdu mais c'est comme ça que l'on
fantasme sur des mythes
merci maman